[Musique]
la devise a aussi impacté la santé au
travail des entreprises yvelinoise ont
mis en place des protocoles pour
garantir le bien-être de leurs salariés
le ministre en charge de cette question
laurent pietra c'est ce qui s'est rendu
sur mer et la part de variants continue
d'augmenter dans le nombre de
contaminations 40 à 45% des carnets de
france seraient liées aux variants glay
de lakovic 19 pour brahim moore qui a le
maître mot est la solidarité ce
restaurateur de mantes-la-jolie offre
depuis plusieurs semaines des mots pas
gratuits aux personnes dans le besoin
l aventure de louis burton et de bureau
vallée continue au moins jusqu'en 2026
le récent troisième du vendée globe
change aussi de bateau avec l'achat de
l'occitane en provence voilier de toute
dernière génération
c'était une promesse d' emmanuel macron
les repas un euro au crous pour tous les
étudiants mis en place depuis le mois de
janvier les repas peuvent dorénavant
être pris sur place les élections
régionales et départementales sont
reportés de mars à juin le parlement a
adopté ce report par un vote à main
levée les dates précises ne sont pas
encore définis le latmos continue de
faire l'actualité après l' us cussac
c'est du côté de mars que les regards se
tournent
le rover persévérance a bien atterri sur
la planète rouge le latmos a développé
une partie de l'électronique qui
commandera super calme
un spectromètre
[Musique]